In Egypt, a Russian airline rules out any technical failure...
...or human error in Saturday's crash and blames "external reasons"...
...for the disaster that killed all 224 people aboard.
In Syria, the Russian defense ministry says its air force bombed...
...the area around the Islamic State-held ancient city of Palmyra.
In Switzerland, the United Nations refugee agency...
...says that with little more than 218,000 arrivals,...
...October's migrant flow to Europe roughly matched the whole of 2014.
Heavy snow blankets northwest China's Xinjiang Uighur Autonomous Region,...
...seriously disrupting local traffic.
And finally from Mexico, Mexican navy rescues four fishermen from Colombia and Ecuador...
...who spent more than a month adrift in a small boat.